welcome everybody my name is clinton
jones and i believe the new year isn't a
new year without some growth it's a
chance for us to learn from last year so
we can challenge ourselves and grow this
year so i say we kick off 2022 with a
challenge
[Music]
i'm proud to announce the infinite
journeys 3d community challenge so
during the month of february i challenge
you whether you're new to 3d or not to
download the template 3d file in the
description and create the 3d scene that
you see in your head because in march
i'm piecing them all together so we can
create the chillest character based 3d
travel montage the internet has ever
laid eyes on you have one month to let
your passion run wild and put your
creativity to the test it doesn't matter
how much experience you have what
program you use or where you're from
this is for every 3d artist looking for
a fun challenge but before we get into
any details i am proud to announce an
amazing prize pool donated from
companies whose products i use and love
and they're all ready to be shipped to
any winning artist around the globe so i
know a lot of artists are trying to
learn unreal engine this year and even a
little bit of houdini so if your render
comes in fifth place mograph.com
is going to help you out with your
choice of any course on their site we're
talking a 40-hour houdini course a
20-hour unreal course by my good friend
winbush six hour procreate course for
you 2d enthusiasts and an ar workflow
lesson by none other than don allen
stevenson iii the guys at mograph.com
are awesome people and i am honored to
have them as part of the infinite
journeys challenge moving on to fourth
place a mograph.com course
that's yours plus
this incredible holographic display from
looking glass factory it's called the
looking glass portrait and it displays
your custom art and more in 3d no glass
is needed the looking glass supports
blender unreal engine and unity if
you're trying to export art specifically
for the looking glass you can even make
interactive experiences with this thing
and convert any photo for 3d display the
possibilities are endless with this
thing and i'm excited for you to see how
cool it is in person let me tell you
about third place though so the third
place artists get a looking glass too as
well as their choice of a monograph.com
course but also one of my all-time
favorite tools it keeps my bones healthy
and my art looking good and i'm talking
about a wacom intuos pro tablet in the
prize pool on behalf of the wonderful
people at wacom now a buddy of mine
bruce got me hooked on these tablets a
long time ago at first i was like i
don't know but if i'm gonna use a
computer for the rest of my life why not
be healthy about it now this wacom
intuos pro tablet is a must for any
artist working on a computer if risk
longevity isn't enough for you wacom is
letting you choose between a small
medium or large this one is a medium i
think it works perfect for my setup but
it's up to you depending on your setup
you can't go wrong
i'm going to take this to the grave
now if your 3d creation comes in second
place you're getting two extra things
actually on top of the mograph.com
course the looking glass portrait and a
wacom intuos pro tablet maxxon is
throwing in an annual max on one
subscription now that's complete with
cinema 4d of course redshift forger and
the entire red giant suite i've been
using cinema4d for nearly 10 years now
and i am honored to officially have
maxon join us as a sponsor this year and
i mentioned two things because our good
friends at rococo are throwing in a pair
of smart gloves for all the professional
level finger tracking you can get your
hands on now these babies are gonna save
lives when you're trying to animate all
this kind of stuff i can't wait to see
what kind of magic you come up with when
you get your hands on a pair of these
and the lucky artist who creates their
next masterpiece during the infinite
journeys 3d challenge
we'll receive the mograph.com course the
looking glass portrait a wacom intuos
pro tablet the maxon one annual
subscription the pair of smart gloves
and a full
performance capture bundle from the
beautiful people at rococo which ships
with not only the smart gloves and their
brand new smart suit pro 2 but a face
capture license and a face cap body
mount to make animation a blast
personally i can't wait to get my hands
on their new suit because they not only
improved its accuracy and performance
from the first version but added
elevation tracking unlocking a whole new
level of mocap options but that is not
all on behalf of the wonderful people at
camp mograph they are hooking you up
with an all-expenses paid trip to join
myself and an entire community of 3d
artists in silver beach virginia in
september for cambograff 2022 colbit
permitting campmograph is hands down the
greatest 3d artist meetup of all time
where a bunch of incredible 3d artists
step away from their computers and into
nature to hang out play games and learn
from each other for like five days
straight last year was my first time and
i had the honor of teaching a service
imperfection class and even a couple
yoga classes it was my favorite event of
last year and i wouldn't miss it for
anything this year so i'm excited to see
you there i want to give a very big
thank you to our sponsors maxon rococo
camp mograph wacom looking glass factory
and mograph.com for sponsoring infinite
journeys and keeping these prizes
available internationally it's very
important they stay international and
you guys really hooked it up so here's
how you join first download the project
file in the description inside we got a
blender file unreal engine c4d and an
fbx file the scene is the same
regardless of what program you're using
once you open up the project file you'll
be looking at a center framed window on
a wall which you're going to turn into
any mode of transportation that you want
that looks out to any setting you want
this challenge is simple because there's
only four simple rules rule number one
keep your mode of transportation moving
to the right so whatever's on the other
side of your window should be scrolling
to the left rule number two you must
capture the sense of movement it's not a
travel montage if we don't feel like
we're moving right rule number three you
gotta add at least one character between
the camera and the window because it's
gonna be boring without a subject and
rule number four
do not touch the camera this ensures
each render connects to the next via the
window as our universal focal point and
that's it the rest is up to you and how
far your creativity and passion will
take you this month and i know we're
going far together yo you all got this
now if you've done these community
challenges before you know it's a great
way to learn and grow no matter your
skill level or program of choice
so to the artists who want to get into
3d this is a perfect opportunity let's
jump in and for you veterans out there i
can't wait to see what you all whip up
the submission deadline is sunday
february 27th at 11 59 pm pst and a
submission link will be provided two
weeks into the challenge on february
12th i'll also announce the mystery
judge judges as we get further into
february and finally you know i'm not
going to leave you all hanging while you
create so to get started myself and the
create with clint discord moderators put
together a series of questions to help
you generate a unique idea for your 3d
scene as well as a short list of faqs to
keep you on the right track the server
is our home base during the infinite
journeys challenge and beyond because
it's full of passionate artists looking
to share their works and progress and
give out pointers to the artists who may
need them so be sure to hop in so you
don't miss important announcements or
updates and for the month of february i
will see each and every one of you every
single saturday as i live stream my
infinite journeys submission y'all i
can't wait to learn grow and create
through this challenge with everybody so
let's crush it and i'll see you guys at
10 45 am pst saturday the 5th so we can
work on this together now go get it
peace
[Music]
you